and the people building Durango Casino  Resort topping off that Tower today as  our drone video shows you some of that  area Station Casinos put the final Beam  on top of the 15-story building a little  before 11 o'clock today and they're very  excited about this future project  we've had this site for a long time and  we've been waiting just for the right  time to open we think it's going to be a  great addition to the community  we are understanding that Durango Casino  Resort expected to open in the fall of  next year meantime workers got a chance  to sign that final beam before it was  hoisted into position over 1200  full-time jobs will be added once it's  complete